Constance Hayes author of the real thing
truth and power at the coca-cola company
where did you get the truth and power at
the coca-cola company well it came out
of the the researching of the book and
the theme I kept returned to was what's
really real here what are people being
told here this is the premier marketing
company of all time probably and I kept
asking myself you know what is the truth
here it was it was sometimes hard to
find why a book but I covered them for a
long time for The Times and then I
became increasingly interested in the
history of the company and the
personalities and you can't always
explore that in a newspaper so I put in
a proposal and here we are deep in the
book you write about the 26th of January
2000 and you say would be the day their
great faith in an American icon crumbled
the day the world they knew and counted
on collapsed the day their trust went up
in smoke
what was that all about there was a huge
layoff at coca-cola unprecedented in the
company's history and it was an effort
to turn around would have been sort of a
stumbling business for almost a year by
then and they'd tried to accomplish it
by laying off about 5200 people they
originally announced 6,000 layoffs and
shrank the number in the end it was
devastating to people not just people
who worked for coke but people from
Atlanta and people who'd grown up with
coke and always knew it is this great
sort of company that cared for you and
company that you worked for until you
really had to had to go either through
retirement or death it was just a sea
change in the culture of that company
how many total employees that they have
they had about 29,000 worldwide at that
point and about 6,000 of them were in
Atlanta at the headquarters and they got
rid of about half the people at the
headquarters and the rest came from
other parts of the world what had
happened well the company had been in
kind of the slide for a number of
reasons have been harder to grow the
business for various reasons some of
which were economic you know it is with
the Asian economies for example in other
places where coke had gotten a lot of
its growth and then there have been some
sort of public problems like a racial
discrimination lawsuit and a product
recall in Belgium none of the problems
were immense on there
but together they added up to but some
board members evidently thought was a
problem in the leadership so they got
rid of the leader and then they did
these cuts to try to fix everything the
day we're taping this the in the middle
of February the stock is at about 51
what's the highest it's ever been and I
know they've been a lot of splits in
this whole business and what's the
lowest it's ever been
well the highest you know accounting for
the splits and everything was about $88
a change in July of 1998 and the lowest
it's been in all this I think was in the
30s the low 30s and it's never actually
regained the level that it had the day
that those layoffs were announced
actually the day that Doug I Auster left
it was about 67 dollars a share it's not
gotten back up at that point
when did you start covering coke I
started covering them actually the day
rubber togas would have died I had to
help out in his obituary and that was in
mid October 1997 and the company was
going great guns I mean they had
incredible growth year after year
they've been posting these magnificent
numbers for 16 years under Gazeta and it
continued for about maybe nine months
after he died and then I started to turn
the name goes Wetty and you even help us
today to say it in the book is what
what's where's it coming oh he's Cuban
he's from Cuba he was part of the elite
class in Cuba that had to leave under
Castro and he relocated to the States he
had worked for coke in Cuba as well and
then he relocated here and made a name
for himself within the company and rose
up to the very top we you don't have
pictures in your book but we got some
pictures because these characters you
write about actually I wanted to see
what they look like
what was his impact because what is
impact well he transformed the company
from a company that simply made a
product to a company that was also a
great financial performer on Wall Street
and he was able to function as almost
kind of a sage or a sphinx sometimes
with Wall Street and to tell people we
are going to make this number in this
target and he always made it or exceeded
it so investors loved him Wall Street
analysts loved him he was he was revered
really and toward the end of his life he
had become
kind of a chairman he was active as
chairman but he became somebody who also
was you know sounding fourth on
management issues for companies besides
just his own you say that coca-cola
headquarters didn't allow smoking but he
smoked all the time oh here's a huge
chain smoker in fact there many scenes
in the book where he's thinking behind a
cigarette and smoking cigarettes and
unfortunately led to lung cancer in his
case and that was what he died from at a
relatively young age he was a not quite
66 why would he smoke in the
headquarters and he wouldn't let anybody
else do it I think he probably would
have let other people do it but it was a
law so I think they were trying to abide
by the law except where he was concerned
let's go back to the to the some overall
statistics how many cokes are consumed
every day in the world so in the world
I think it's a billion a day now maybe a
little bit more and 365 billion a year
right that's a lot is it the biggest
drink in the world it is the biggest
drink I mean that number is not just
coca-cola it's all the other products
they make as well things like Minute
Maid and bottled water but coke is still
the lead product and the leader in terms
of the profitability for the company
when was the first coke made it was made
in 1886 and it was made in Atlanta and
behind a drugstore counter by a man
named John Pemberton who was fooling
around with another remedy he had made
trying to take the alcohol out of it and
then he he put the soda water into it
and took a sip and thought it was great
and began to sell it from that one
little counter and he didn't do that all
that much with Coke in the beginning he
had it for about two years and then a
very forward-thinking man named ASA
Candler who was a competitor of his down
the road bought the formula from him and
just loved it it helped cure his
headaches you know it did have cocaine
at that point a cocaine extract and ASA
Keller was a believer and he persuaded
people all over the South first and then
all over the country to sell coca-cola
by by name so he was sort of the the
master marker behind the whole thing and
by 1895 he would claim that it was sold
in every single state and I think that
was true so the cocaine everybody always
asked about that
how long was their cocaine in it and how
much was it and now what did how did it
affect people I don't know the exact
proportion of the cocaine but it was
very little it was a cocaine extract and
in those days in 1886 cocaine was
regarded as a harmless analgesic it
wasn't until 1899 that people got very
upset about drugs and things and and the
backlash began and he took a Candler
took the cocaine out he took the potent
part of the cocaine out and left sort of
an extract in there that was not not as
strong so what are the other ingredients
in coca-cola there is a oil of coriander
oil of neroli which is kind of like an
orange blossom oil of some other citrus
fruits oil of cinnamon and then of
course there's Cola which comes from the
Kola nut and then there's a ton of sugar
you know bright actually they don't use
sugar the original formula had cane
sugar and a few places around the world
you can still get the coke made with
cane sugar but by-and-large is now made
with high-fructose corn syrup
what's the difference between high
fructose corn syrup and sugar well one's
a lot cheaper than the other high
fructose corn syrup is very cheap it's a
commodity and one of the changes
actually goes Weda made was to introduce
that as a substitute for sugar which
kind of got around some of the contracts
that they had with the bottlers at that
time what year did they start diet coke
that coke was 1982 and it was an
innovation that was also it also enabled
the company to get around these
contracts with the bottlers and i spent
some time in the book talking about a
group of bottlers who sued the company
saying you know you can't you can't
introduce diet coke like this you know
you can't introduce this different kind
of coke formula we're bound by a an
agreement that dates back to 1920 that
says the syrup is supposed to have a
certain amount of cane sugar in it I
think it's five pounds and change per
gallon and you're not abiding by the
contract so there's a very protracted
legal battle over that that the bobbler
is more or less lost
what's your suspicion about the taste of
coke today versus 1886 I think it
probably tastes different I mean people
there are people who remember the cane
sugar coke and say it doesn't taste the
same and I pretty much grew up on the
kind that has the corn syrup so I can't
tell the difference what's there
amount of Diet Coke sold compared to the
classic coke you know well there's more
classic coke sold you know over all
around the world than Diet Coke
but Diet Coke is very popular too now I
want to personalize it just for a moment
because as I was reading your book I
this image kept popping in my mind I
grew up in a small town in Indiana
Lafayette Indiana and there was a man
named Dan Casey who was still very much
alive today who was the coca-cola
bottler his father had been the
coca-cola bottler in that town where I
lived
but I remember Dan Casey I knew him well
as a kid because he was always doing
things for people contributing I had a
radio show he advertised on he would
contribute to the high school he's a
high school basketball star and all that
stuff how how how much is that like
other towns in America where the
coca-cola bottle was that he was know
everybody in town knew it
that is it that is an experience
repeated a thousand times around the
country I mean the coca-cola bottler
became a fixture in these towns somebody
once compared them to the fire
department in the post office as an
institution a town really couldn't get
along without and that was the magic of
it all I mean these were independent
guys they started bottling bottling
began independently of the coca-cola
company and these independent
franchisees had exclusive rights to sell
coke within a certain area maybe 50
square miles or however much it was and
they became not just sellers of coke but
really active people in their
communities it so much so that people
wanted to drink coke because they liked
them you know the flipside is maybe they
were afraid not to because they knew
them but they contributed money they
contributed their time they serve him
all the boards of the important
institutions they had kids in schools
they invited other kids in to see the
plant they hired people in these
neighborhoods in these towns you know
and lots of places where there was no
other industry there was a coke bottling
plant you know clinking along with this
wonderful brown stuff going in and
people felt that it was part of them
because they saw it being made right in
their town in fact a lot of the bottling
plants were designed with a great big
glass window in front so even if you
weren't going in you could walk by and
watch it Dan Casey's bottling company
headed windows you could stand and watch
their bottles go by I remember
as a kid going down there to see it was
a trip we took down here to see it yeah
it's an amazing thing did it give you
something at the end like a ruler or a
pencil oh sure yeah so that was normal
that was normal I'm sure made a big
impression you were probably the fourth
grade is that right yeah well they
always started what about the free
ticket thing that they used to do oh
that was in the very beginning that was
ASIC and ler he was the guy who bought
the formula from Pemberton and he
offered free tickets as a way of getting
people to try it for the first time and
they must have issued millions of these
free tickets and people cashed them and
it was a great way to get people to try
a new drink when was Pepsi started Pepsi
began 1898
so Pepsi is always sort of the kid
brother to coke and it started sort of
the same way in a pharmacist you know
you know in a pharmacy and it was a man
named Caleb Bradham who started it down
a New Bern North Carolina and the
parallel sort of growths of Pepsi and
Coca are very different I mean they both
became very big but Pepsi had numerous
flirtations with bankruptcy I think coke
at one point almost bought it and the
great key for Pepsi was to switch to
these other bottles bottles during the
Depression they went to much larger 12
ounce bottles and had that jingle about
twice as much for nickel - and they
really made inroads on coke at that
point so then you had the beginnings of
the cola wars which we all you know have
done for years you say that coke has 44
percent of the market in this country or
maybe it's the world and Pepsi has 31
percent that's in this country yeah it's
berry and how long has that been that
way and is anybody gaining on the other
no you know in fact cola sales have been
flat for a long time I mean they've
fought to declining since about 1984 and
the Pepsi challenge which led to this
thing that we know is new coke was
something that allowed Pepsi to gain
some market share at the expense of coke
but the whole market hasn't really grown
very much what's the Pepsi challenge
Pepsi challenge was in the in the 70s
and 80s there was a blindfolded taste
test that Pepsi would televise and
they'd have a confirmed coke drinker
coming and tried two different cups of
of soda well most Pepsi one was coke and
he'd be asked to say which one he liked
the best and he invariably said on the
air and he liked the Pepsi best without
knowing
you know which one when it was so that
went on and on on I think it drove the
Pepsi or the Koch executives crazy and
they decided to develop this new formula
which became known as new coke it was
essentially Pepsi it wasn't real Pepsi
sort of pretend Pepsi the Pepsi people
all made fun of it and they said coke is
throwing in the towel and they made a
huge amount of them but the real
reaction came from coke drinkers because
in introducing new coke coke took
regular coke off the market so all
sudden it wasn't there was no choice you
there had to have new coke or nothing
and the bottlers actually you know
intervene after about two months and
said you've got to stop this because you
know our guys can't go out into the
streets anymore we've got people who are
afraid to go play golf at their golf
club because they're being yelled at for
for new coke and was a huge outcry from
coke drinkers go back again to the start
date on the new coke and who was CEO at
the time it was a good sweater because
right at Keo and I'm still all on the
job then and they goes what on Keo and a
couple of other executives announced it
with great pride at various you know
sites around the country and they said
it had a different taste and it was this
wonderful improvement on coke and that
was in 1985 April of 1985 before we go
any farther I got to show a picture of
Don Quixote gotta tell us who he is okay
what role did he play in coca-cola
company well in the book I refer to him
as the heart of the coca-cola company he
was sort of the ultimate salesman the
guy who padded everybody on the back who
knew everybody and he's still alive of
course he's he's still around you know
it hasn't an advisory role at coke now
but he's um as you can see in the
picture he's you know very jovial and
people like to be around him and he was
president of coke for about 12 years why
well because what it was the chairman
and CEO he said that when he left the
company there were 3,000 people at a
6,000 person headquarters that went out
and shook his hand outside the bill
right out in the hot Sun you know
wearing buttons that say we salute a
real classic and there was a great love
for him there's a great affinity for him
they went beyond sort of his job I mean
I think he really made these connections
with people that that they appreciated
and remembered but he leads in your
story to some drama later on
where he went on to work for Frank Allen
and company explain what Allen the
company is they're an investment bank
and the sort of you know merger advisory
firm in Manhattan headed by Herbert
Allen who's also on the code board and
donkey landed there after retiring from
coke at age 66 or so and you know did
got business for them in various ways
and in the book I talk about how Kia
watched was sort of increasing alarm
while during his absence things changed
at Koch and I think he was very very
passionate about the brand and about the
business and the company and all the
people there and began to voice his
displeasure you know with various people
probably including Herbert Allen and
that ultimately led to John to Doug I
was reducing his job let me show a
picture of duster
what year how many years was he CEO at
coke he was there for just about two
years two years in a couple of months
when did he come in he came in when goes
what had died and he was the hand-picked
successor to his widow and that's not a
very nice picture of him but he's he
does smile sometimes and he was a guy
who was well versed in the financial had
created a lot of the financial
underpinnings of the coca-cola company
during the Gazeta era and because what I
think admired him very much and wanted
him to succeed him I talked to somebody
who knew up all about this conversation
between Gazoo Etta and IVA ster
basically I guess what his deathbed and
in which I roasted look if he want me to
go when you go I'm happy to do that you
can have anybody you want and goes what
I said no no no you're the one that I
want and and I do believe that
conversation so after after the trouble
started there were a lot of stories
about how because what I really hadn't
had wanted him and that kind of thing
but I found no evidence of that in my
research you said it in the
acknowledgments in the fact that some
people when they talk to you didn't want
to be identified he said many people
even if they had left the company were
reluctant to speak on the record
citing fear of retribution through
social channels blame that well if you
live in Atlanta for example or any place
where coke is very big and important
there were ways that I think they feared
they might be hurt that you know their
wives might be working for something and
shut out of some event or they
themselves might feel uncomfortable on
the golf course or you know there were
way I mean Elena is still in many way
it's a very small town and it's in many
ways still dominated by coca-cola I felt
sorry for them I thought it was terrible
to be that afraid if you weren't working
there anymore but that's what they said
and I chose to go with it who talked to
you on the record that we have
importance in the book Webster he didn't
want to talk to me but I talked to her
but Allen on the record Donald McHenry
let's see who else couldn't talk to good
sweat oh he was gone by then what about
Donny hill a couple of things he I did
get him to say on a record so I want to
show the Board of Directors because you
mentioned Donald McHenry some people may
remember him in his past life as what
well he's still a professor at
Georgetown at the school of foreign
relations and a very thoughtful man he
was a diplomat in the Carter
Administration you an ambassador right
from the United States we'll put the
list there on the screen you see Douglas
daft who's currently the chairman herb
Allen
Ron Allen Kathleen black at Hearst
magazine company used to be the
publisher of USA Today Warren Buffett
and he plays it what kind of role big
name in this book right he well he's the
principal investor at one point in coke
I mean he still is he's got about 200
million shares which is a lot of money
through Berkshire Hathaway and he
becomes disgruntled with IVA stir too in
this book and he and Allen fly to
Chicago to basically fire IVA stir in an
airplane hangar on December 1st 1999
it's not very long ago let's put that
list back up this for a second former
senator Sam Nunn is on the list he's
from Georgia Jimmy Robinson used to run
the American Express Company
Peter you virologist be baseball
commissioner for candidate for governor
out in California and who is James
Williams
he's an Atlanta and he's a former
chairman of the SunTrust Bank and
longtime coca-cola board member there
are three women on that list kathleen
black susan king maria elena lager
marcinho right how long how long have
there been women on the board there
always have been women in one form or
another like a bottlers wife or
something
but Cathleen Black was the first and
sort of the modern era and she came
along in 1991 she and Susan King came
along about the same time and were put
on the board buckets Wetty but there
hadn't been any women for a while before
that when goes wet it took over the
board apparently was filled with cronies
of Robert Woodruff who was sort of the
patriarch of coke for about 60 years he
built it up from a you know sort of
stumbling daughter and kind of company
in the 1920s and you took it abroad did
this deal with Eisenhower to provide
coke to the GIS during World War two
created a huge generation of coke
loyalists that way and really is
responsible for great success within the
company did you say 10 billion cokes
were given to GIS yeah 41 to 45 10
billion coke yeah do they give it to
them or they sell it to they sold to
them they had to pay for it was a nickel
but they promised that they would have
it they like in every theater of war
they said that we will make sure that
you can get your coke and I heard a
great story from a friend of mine named
Tom Evans recently who went fishing in
in Havana Harbor in the New Hebrides
which is in the southwest South Pacific
and during the war a lot of American
soldiers were stationed there and they
were given five cokes a day and they
apparently threw their bottles into the
water so if you go down there now that
the sand has a screen is tantrum all the
coke bottle glass it's come to be part
of the environment where'd the name
coca-cola come from well the coca is
obviously cocaine and the cola is from
the Kola nut and it was a name that
Pemberton thought of I think on the spot
and his assistant wrote it out in his
flowin cursive and it looks pretty much
the same apparently as what he wrote on
that first day is that the same
Pemberton from the Civil War it's not
but it's so interesting because the
first the Pemberton from the Civil War
is the the Confederate General who
basically lost the siege at Vicksburg to
the Yankees and the Vicksburg who
becomes the site of the very first coke
bottle bottling operation a kind of
unofficial bottling by a guy who had a
candy company a guy named Beaton horn
and he just thought it'd be a good idea
to put coke and bottles he sent a bunch
to ASA Candler Kendler said fine but it
wasn't that was in about 1892 and it
wasn't until several years later that
the real bottling of coca-cola began
that was in 1899
what's the total revenues for a
coca-cola company today oh gosh it's
about um I never get this right it's
about sixteen billion dollars seventeen
billion dollars a year and if how many
places did you personally go and trying
to research this this story well I
always wished I'd gone to more I mean as
a reporter and a writer you always think
you can do a little more if you just add
one more trip but I went to Rome Georgia
which has the highest per-capita
consumption of coke anywhere in the
world is something like 900 cokes a year
for every man woman and child which
works out to be about three a day don't
go any farther I got it why they love it
and there's a great
there was a bottler there for years a
family modeler for three generations and
the current the guy who sold it recently
is named James Franck baron and frank
baron is referred to as marcus aurelius
when he walks around Rome Georgia I mean
he's that important the guy and he like
your friend is a huge contributor to
everything that's important in that town
from the the private schools to the
public baseball field he's done it all
and they're wonderfully respected and
admired people in that town but he
actually sold his company in 1986 to
what became coca-cola enterprises he and
he decided to get out of the business
for various reasons it had to do with
not being able to grow the way he wanted
to and some changes were taking place in
the sort of the economic landscape at
large like the growth of Walmart like
the growth of there's large supermarket
chains that were no longer regional or
local but but national in scope because
what happened was all these little
bottlers had different arrangements for
either delivery or pricing or whatever
and these big sellers of coke like
Walmart wanted to make a single deal and
have it all acted upon the same way and
you couldn't always get if you were the
coca-cola company you couldn't always
get the bottlers to go along with that
every single time so hence the formation
of this mega bottler here's the cover of
your book and you can see the lady there
holding up a coke bottle and of course
the real thing one of the slogans and
the red where did the red come from you
know I'm not sure but it was a popular
color where did the shape of the bottle
come from oh that's easy that's um that
was
commissioned by ASIC handler in about
1915 he wanted a uniform bottle because
they've been using all kinds of bottles
up until that point and depending on
where you were as a bottle or you used
what was at hand so there may be
straight sided bottles blue bottles
white bottles amber bottles it
there's nothing sort of uniform about it
and he wanted to have a single
representative bottle for coca-cola so
he commissioned this bottle design from
the route Glass Company in Indiana and
the designer went to the library and
looked up : that and it wasn't in the
encyclopedia
so the librarian apparently pointed him
toward the the cocoa bean so those ribs
you see on the bottle are actually
evoking a cocoa bean and that silhouette
is meant to evoke either a hoop skirt or
a hobble skirt which is sort of a
popular style you know in the the period
when coca-cola came to be who was
responsible for the plastic bottle and
the 20-ounce which changed a lot of
things that was done after that was an
innovation he that he came up with it
that sold a lot more coke for a company
and also was seen as a way for the
bottlers to make more money - by selling
a larger package okay we're in the
middle of several stories that we
haven't completed I want to go back
we've met
we're sweater and Doug I've astir and
Don Quixote course Wetty and new coke
again what year was new coke introduced
1985 how much planning was there for
that a lot of planning I think at the
end they began planning for it shortly
after goods what I became chairman and
may have even been some rumblings about
it before but again it's coming out of
this worried about the Pepsi challenge
they feel like they need to change the
formula and make it more competitive
with Pepsi so we make this thing that is
flatter than coke in terms of the
bubbles it's sweeter than coke in terms
of the flavor and it's a lot like Pepsi
except when the Pepsi people open it up
and try it for the first time al burst
out laughing because it's not as good as
Pepsi in their opinion so they feel that
they've won the cola wars and you know
they're they're merciless and they're
needling of coke they take out these big
ads and they go our own and talk on TV
about how Coke has finally given up and
this it was humiliating for Coke and
later
I think somebody a coke tried to say
that you know what was all
plan and we just wanted to revive
interest in coke and you know we
succeeded in that but there's a famous
quote from John keel where he says you
know we're not that smart we're not that
dumb I think one of those things that it
was a plan hatched in sort of a
corporate ivory tower didn't work they
brought back the regular coke they kept
both on the market for a long time and
new coke just very slowly died on the
vine so was there a day all of a sudden
new coke was available everywhere yeah
it was in April like mid April of 1985
and was supposed to go overseas as well
but they never got that far because the
hue and cry in this country was so
enormous and it was the bottlers who
were these independent guys you know
kind of selling the coke to you and me
who reported back to coke that you know
this really isn't working and it's just
a terrible thing for our business and
for our lives and you've got to do
something
so after 77 days old coke comes back
because what a more or less admits he's
made a mistake and he says you know you
people who drink new coke you're making
the drinking the best coke we've ever
made but for all of you other people we
just want to say we've heard you and now
you're going to have you know a choice I
mean for 77 days the old Coke was not
available right and that whole issue of
not having a choice to me is so
revealing of the way that they were
thinking that that that they could
arbitrarily change the flavor of coke
and nobody would worry about it if
people just kind of go along and buy it
I mean there was so much emotion and
nostalgia and and love really invested
in coke as it was that I think to take
it away it's like taking away a baby's
bottle I mean people just burst into
tears and wrote angry letters and
there's some great letters I think I
quote from in that story where people
write you know dear chief dodo you know
whose idea was this and they were they
were pretty hard on the company what
happened inside the company right after
the announcement was made and they
started to feel that people didn't like
this idea I think they first tried to
kind of bat it away and say oh we've
only had 40,000 calls you know it's not
that bad but after like the 400,000 call
they realized that it was bad and then
these bottlers who we can't
underestimate the role the bottlers in
this they go marching down to Atlanta
and they say you're killing us you know
you were killing the brand you've got to
listen to us and the coca-cola company
did listen to them and and it was the
right move because you know they they
brought back regular coke and and
everybody was happy again was Doug Irish
true there then
he was there that yeah I'm not sure how
much role he had in developing and
marketing new coke what about Don Q he
was still CFO Don K was there was he
behind all this that he liked this idea
I think he did I mean I think they're
all on board when they announced it do
they need more money at this time um
they they never really need more money
but they'd like more money why it's just
business I mean they money's there they
want to go after it and that that's
what's at the root of their issues with
the bottlers you know because the
bottlers start off independently
everyone a coke it's at night in 1898
thinks the bottling is gonna be a total
disaster and it turns out to be a great
success I mean the bottling putting
coconut coke because but I didn't know
actually when I first started
researching the book was it until
eighteen eight ninety nine really you
couldn't get a coke except at a soda
fountain you had to go in there and it
was a big public place and people got
dressed up and then you had to live in a
place it had a soda fountain which
wasn't everywhere and the idea of
putting it into bottles meant that a
farmer could come and get it and go back
to to work or you could have it in a
baseball stadium or you could have it
you know in the car with you you could
take it home you could have it when you
wanted to have it not just you know
during the hours at a soda fountain
wasn't was open and to me that the
bottlers really democratized coke in a
way that that made the company
unbelievably strong but this jealousy
began this like little I call a little
fire that began to burn Atlanta and
would never go out I mean it was this
this anger over the the money that the
bottlers were making and just somehow
you know invaded coke and stayed there
for you know more than 80 years until
they were able to kind of try to
rejigger their relationship with this
big bobbler called coca-cola enterprises
coca-cola enterprises was started in
what year by it was started in 1986 so a
hundred years after the first Coke was
served they came up with a solution to
the bottling issue as they thought of it
and it's actually Doug iris theirs idea
to take all these bottlers who were
interested in selling wasn't just Frank
Barron who was a small dollar but there
were big bottlers like the LA bobbler
was on the block and a couple of other
ones like the one headed by jackal Upton
who's one of the very first bottlers out
of Chattanooga he about 10% of the coke
Empire was was his and they put these
things on the block it's that we're
selling we went a billion dollars you
know take it off her hands and coke was
you know enormous ly fearful of what
would
if some some other owner came in and had
that much of the business and maybe
started telling them what to do so I
ever sir had this idea to take to buy
these Butler's up and then create a new
entity which would own the bottlers
taking the debt for example off Coca
Cola's books and they created this new
Butler that was you know more responsive
to coke they put they coke kept as a
forty nine percent equity stake at first
and so they had a lot of say in the
bottlers operations put people on the
board and on paper it was a great idea
because instead of having you know 50 or
so people that you had to deal with on a
big contract you instead had one I mean
had that whoever was CEO of coca-cola
enterprises was your man versus 50
people with competing interests or
different agendas and so 86 from
coca-cola enterprises today how much of
that business how much of the bottling
business do they own in the United
States they are 80% today and and
beginning they own about 30% into they
own a hundred percent of these bottlers
now are they still do the 49 percent Oh
Coco Coco's reduces take a little bit I
think they're down to about 40 percent
now in coca-cola enterprises but it's
still a very big stake and you said in
your book at Howard Buffett is the
chairman of the board of coca-cola
enterprises he thought that Germany is
one of the board members one of the
board yeah enterprises but it's filled
with people from SunTrust and from you
know with different connections to coke
so and SunTrust is the big banker in
Italy
Jerry Williams a bank right I'm tired
now though I should point that out he's
from his retirement on the board or from
the from central so here we are today
you've got two companies Coke and Coke :
er prizes right how much debt does coke
a coke has very little debt almost no
debt coca-cola enterprises has a ton of
death there's so much debt that they
can't make enough money most most years
to just service the death because part
of your story unfolds do the factory are
these two companies and one has a lot of
debt one doesn't its share price right
when did share price become so important
in this country
Roberto goes what I made share price the
sort of gold doubloon and he put on the
mass of coca-cola and said this is what
we're all after this is what's gonna
make us strong and to his credit he
inspired people to work hard for a share
price
he had monitors with the share price in
all the coca-cola lobbies he you know
consistently referred to share price as
a measure of sort of how well people
were doing employees invested heavily in
401k is that were all coca-cola stock
because of the share price going up and
it went up and up and up four years and
split you know a number of times under
him either three for one or two for one
and people who had held coke stock for
years just kind of woke up and thought
wow this is a great company you know and
coke has always been held by many many
individual investors there hasn't been a
ton of institutional investing in coke
so lots of you know old ladies in
Decatur got got rich from their coke
stock all of a sudden and lots of people
who had family coke stock they basically
ignored for a long time suddenly had
tons of wealth as well and and it was
this kind of miracle in Atlanta and you
know I think for a long time it was it
was really working and it was real there
was you know a lot of there were a lot
of emerging markets to tap into there
was other ways to to make the the
bottling and other aspects of coca-cola
more efficient to save money on that end
and it began to taper I believe in about
1992 or three because things changed we
got to a certain peak of the experience
and then it got harder and harder to do
but they managed to keep pulling it off
pulling off and you know some of the
things I do I wrote about in the book
and I think that they they caught up
with him after a while you talk about a
fella deep in the book by the name of
it's either Albert mayor or Meyer Meyer
from Elkhart Indiana right who is from
South Africa but he worked in Elkhart he
was a guy who had been he's a sort of
ferocious accountant he believes in
accounting more than I ever thought
anyone can believe in accounting but he
believes that accountants are the
gatekeepers of society and he felt that
cokes accounting was not completely fair
and forthright and he examined the books
of coca-cola enterprises versus the
books of coca-cola came up with these
sort of comparisons of how much Jack
Coke had a versus the bottler felt that
the bobbler was really subject to Coke
in a way that meant their book should be
consolidated and that that just you know
upset the code people immensely because
to them the whole issue of creating a
separate company was
in order not to have to consolidate the
books and have all that debt and you
know risk to in bottling is very
capital-intensive business and if you
build too many bottling plants you know
you'll be in trouble you know if you
don't have the volume which coke
actually ran into in other parts of the
world so what did albert meyer doing
this study he came to people at the New
York Times and other people and
published it and you know created quite
a wave briefly you know when it came out
and then things kind of came back
together but you know he he ended up
being quite right that there was there
was too much leverage I could quote
coca-cola enterprises they couldn't
really afford the kinds of purchases
they were making and you know that and
moreover the demand for coke was not
there as anticipated they had
anticipated these huge numbers coming in
of you know just growing demand growing
demand growing demand and that really
wasn't happening with coca-cola anyway I
mean that the business had been falling
off for a long time and there lots of
competitors and coca-cola enterprises
isn't just an American bobbler now it's
also also got large parts of Western
Europe and that cut into their business
as well you say Albert Meier went to
Texas and get involved in the Tyco story
but he left this small company worked
for in Elkhart Indiana went to worked
for david tights and so shi'ites and
began to analyze Tyco as well and so
several years before anybody else he
said there are serious problems with the
accounting at Tyco he was again shouted
down you know the type of people got
very mad at him but you see he was kind
of right
what's the Belgium story the Belgium
story is the the recall of coca-cola
products the biggest recall he had ever
had in Belgium and it's still somewhat
mysterious as to you know what actually
happened there were people really
sickened by coke or did they really just
think they were sickened but to me it's
a fascinating story because it's
marketing flipped on its head
I mean in marketing a product like Coke
you tell people that they want it and
why they have to want it and why it's
important to them and this is the sort
of you know marketing turned inside out
were cooler saying I don't want coke
it's making me sick I think I'm sick
therefore I am sick I mean it was just a
it was just you know it sort of play in
Reverse you know that was in 1999 1999
was a pretty rough year for the
coca-cola company how much did it spread
around the world
the panic spread everywhere the pink got
to know Singapore and Poland and you
know these places far beyond where the
actual crisis was and the crisis was
really confined to Belgium to a couple
of hundred schoolchildren who reported
feeling ill after coca-cola and Fanta
and they you know eventually found that
there was some sort of yucky stuff on
some of the cans and when in one vending
machine and then that some of the coke
and bottles have been prepared with some
sort of bad smelling sulfur dioxide that
they used to make the bubbles and you
know that was you know it was
unfortunately got sort of blown up by
the sort of you know global media you
know reaction and I think it probably
got bigger than it actually deserved to
be in some ways and Coke Commission
reports saying you know scientific
there's no scientific evidence is this
actually made anybody sick but it almost
didn't matter the facts almost didn't
matter which is why I'm talking about
the sort of dark side of marketing I
mean it's it becomes what people think
about it rather than what is actually
there to support it who was in charge
who's the CEO then the guy sure was
let's see yeah and who put the fire out
he actually you know it's interesting
the the bobbler really had a role to
play here because it was the bottled
drinks that that really should have you
know gotten the most attention
I mean coke as you know makes the syrup
that becomes the bottle or can of soft
drink so by the time somebody's drinking
out of it you know their job is almost
done but the whole brand was imperiled
and so I was there flew to Belgium he
tried to do what he could do he was
somewhat hamstrung by the political
situation in Belgium which coincided
with the dioxin crisis and the whole
government had been thrown out and the
new government was sort of yelling at
coke behind the scenes and saying you
won't do anything until we give you
permission and so it was a very
difficult situation for any CEO he said
the Belgians Belgium's Belgians hated
the Americans in this well certain
Belgian officials had great animus
toward America because of things like
trade embargoes and you know just the
general sort of suspicion of American
culture creeping in and that's something
we're always dealing with as a country
how much money did all this cost coke it
cost coca-cola enterprises a lot more
money than coke but it ended up being I
think I said it in the book it's it's
several million dollars not just two
undo the damage for them to replace all
the soda that had to be destroyed so it
really cut into the bottlers numbers for
that year by the way where did the name
or the phrase soda pop come from oh it
came from the very first bottles used to
bottle a soft drink and it was a bottle
called the Hutchison bottle that had a
rubber stopper in it and a wire kind of
contraption that you pulled up to put
the soda in the bottle then pushed in
when you wanted to drink the soda and
because of the gas involved in in soda
the pushing in of the of the stopper
releases bang and so that was known as
the pop and so the soda became known as
soda pop you said that Rome Georgia is
the biggest drinking coca coca-cola city
in the United States but then he said
that Cleveland is the only city in the
United States for Pepsi beats coke yeah
it's one of the only ones I Cleveland a
buffalo yeah what's the reason
just inroads made early on and you know
preferences are very strong I mean
people get generational sometimes about
whether they drink Coke or Pepsi the
other thing you discuss is how well
first let me ask you about an important
law that was passed the territorial law
okay what year was it what was the pot
went to politics of it and what benefit
was there to coca-cola and other soft
drinks well it was the law that had been
challenged by the FTC and challenged
again and again in court and it became
introduced as a piece of legislation by
a group of people you know with Coke and
Pepsi as approval because what it did
the proposal was to undo these exclusive
franchises that we've been talking about
that allowed the bubblers to have you
know their own sort of special territory
and nobody could sell you know cross
lines and there are people at the FTC
who felt that that was you know unfair
restriction or trade and monopolies and
so forth so there's kind of only one
bottler in a community right or in an
area right it's called it's called the
Interbrand competition act and basically
it was saying is the real competition if
you have these exclusive territories and
ultimately the finding was that you you
do have competition as long as you have
other brands so you could have a very
very powerful coke bottle and as long as
you had some sort of Pepsi bottler can
endure a bottle or dr. pepper
you'd have competition there for a bill
right but the butler's and Coke I think
became very fearful
that the law actually might get changed
and this if it had and all the value of
these franchises would have gone out the
window
and so coke could lobbied hard as did
Pepsi and some other companies to
preserve the law and introduced a piece
of legislation that had wonderful strong
grassroots support because at the time
you had all these little bottlers who
wrote to their legislators in Congress
and said you've got to help us this is
our livelihood and it was passed sort of
over the objections of Jimmy Carter who
was then the president and he sort of
somewhat reluctantly signed it into law
after a few you know changes to the
wording but what it did was preserve
that system and then once it was
preserved then some more some of the
bothers began to sell out because the
value was was set for their their
franchises is there a political image
coming out of coca-cola party-wise one
party or the other they've always kind
of been both I mean I you know gave Jack
Kennedy and bottle of coke to drink and
took his picture and they I think right
now they're probably Republican because
that's who's in power but I don't think
they're especially one way or the other
they ever showed much power in politics
and they'd given a lot of money over the
years they have PACs and things here in
Washington and they have you know
they've supported things like they've
worked against things like the groups
that that try to you know promote you
know healthier lunch menus for example
or banned sodas and in cafeterias I
think Patrick Leahy is run afoul of them
a couple of times so today do they have
exclusive franchises they do yes
you still can't if you if you are a a
coke bottle or you can't have you don't
have to worry about competition from
another coke bottle or coming in selling
in your in your area so they can control
the price they can but you also talked a
lot about one of the figures that was
interesting to me it was a hundred and
twenty thousand convenience stores in
the United States and then you talk
about the grocery stores and they and
the control of the shelves and that a
lot of people's eyes are open when they
read about this they don't realize when
they walk in a grocery no you don't wait
all that well has to be was with display
and Coke and Pepsi and all the companies
are always battling for display and it's
not just about soda it's about every
packaged food you know that's sold in
the store but in cokes case I got very
aggressive Pepsi quickly followed suit
in convenience
stores and they wanted to have you know
the best aisles and the best displays
and you know the center you know doors
on the cooler section and that was all
because they wanted to promote coke at
the expenses of other beverages which is
fine it's legal but some of the
competitors began to complain and there
was a big suit filed by a group of royal
crown distributors and world crown is
always kind of the third you know
runner-up to Coke and Pepsi in the color
Wars but there's a market for it and I
visit Wigner with some Butler's and are
some distributors in in Texas in
Louisiana and Arkansas who ran into this
and they suddenly weren't able to sell
they weren't not only not able to
display but they weren't able to even
put up signs or you know have a
refrigerator case or anything because
coke signed these very aggressive
they're called calendar marketing
agreements but they are you know the
terms under which their product would be
sold in a particular store or chain of
stores and as far as I know it's still
going on there was an appeal of the case
in Texas and the appeal was the appeal
upheld the original verdict which was
that you know coke shouldn't do this it
was coke and coca-cola enterprises and
but I don't think anything's really
changed coke owns what besides coke they
own stakes and many large bottlers all
over the world because coke enterprises
was the prototype for that what they
call an anchor bottler and then it was
duplicated in Australia and you know
Western Europe it's sort of Western
middle Europe there's add there's an
anchor Butler now in Japan that's quite
small but they have hopes for it there
eleven of them all together all over the
world you say also the own minute main
oh right they own the Minute Maid brand
orange juice they own Dasani water they
are larger bear right and Fruitopia is
that there's it's kind of died on the
vine actually is it's going away yeah
they bought they bought old wallet and
fresh samantha lee on that juice company
now the only anything else I mean like
Pepsi owns you say Quaker Oats yeah no
they did they had a they both competed
for Quaker Oats because it had quicker
had a gay rate which is a top-selling
sports drink and Pepsi prevailed in that
one and no coke doesn't own any food
companies or anything like that although
they talk about owning coffee
you know just distribution companies and
things like that but so far they don't
do that and what else is Pepsi Pepsi
owns Quaker Pepsi and frito-lay and
that's the whole you know snack food
division which accounts for most of
their earnings actually at this point
and then they own their Pepsi products
well you aren't writing books about coke
cool what do you do I work for the New
York Times and I cover business stories
and my beat is retail but over the last
you know a few weeks I've been covering
the Martha Stewart trial because that
falls under retail because it Kmart
where did you start all this where'd you
go where you're from or easily
I born in New York City I live ever
cease for a while and went to college in
Boston where overseas in Hong Kong why
my dad's job paper for Exxon and we came
back to the states I went to Harvard and
worked for the Crimson you know sort of
you know occasional way and but I always
knew I wanted to be a journalist and so
when I got out I applied to a whole lot
of newspapers all around the country and
I got my first job at the News and
Observer in Raleigh North Carolina which
is of course Pepsi country but um that
was a great first job I work for people
who you know believes that anybody can
do these stories and we write two and
three stories a day sometimes and it was
a great exciting time and how long you
been two times for 17 years you dedicate
the book for John and for the brave
that's that John was my husband who was
completely in integral to either but sir
both starting the book of finishing the
book what's he do by the way he works
for Christie's he's a deputy chairman at
Christie's and he specializes in
American furniture so he shared my love
of American history and we used to talk
a lot about this book you know late at
night and he was extremely helpful how
long did it take you to do it the book
about three years and and then the other
part of the dedication is for the brave
and I'm I was thinking about the last
lines of the national anthem you know
the land of the free we're all free but
we have to make a choice to be brave and
I I think that book talks a lot about
people who have to do the right thing
and and come forward and challenge
something even something as big as coke
that most of them are afraid of but they
they took it on and when you're talking
about challenging who would you give
credit to challenging well the these
bottlers who had
royal crown in Texas who felt they were
being shut out of the market unfairly
they sued and they won that was in
victory for them and albert meyer who
questioned the the accounting of coke
and was you know sort of yelled at for
that and either been people throughout
cokes history who questioned the
direction of the company and wanted to
know is this the best strategy for us
and and the the one thing i keep
returning to in looking at the
personalities of coke is that everybody
is very passionate about it it's it
invites this emotion that I think most
consumer packaged goods don't and I have
yet to uncover the mystery and the
answer to why that is Anna did Jesse
Jackson get bought off by coke I don't
think so I think he his agenda morphed
over time as well and he wanted to do
different things with them that you know
required different things of them so but
he did make money off of coke didn't he
over the years he received many
contributions oh yeah but um how and
under what circumstance I don't think is
necessarily in their pocket um he
received money and he led a boycott of
coke in 1981 that was very embarrassing
for the company and forced him to make
some changes in terms of who was
distributing coke or bottling coke and
he later on got involved with something
called the wall street project and coke
was a big backer of that and what was
the wall street project there's an
effort to get more maori involvement in
things like underwriting and you know
the sort of banking functions what's the
status of race at coke today it's hard
to tell i mean i think there's still
some bitterness about the lawsuit i
think there what lawsuit the there's a
racial discrimination lawsuit filed with
also in 1999 against coke and it was
brought by for african-american current
and former employees and they wanted to
draw attention to the fact that many
blacks at coke did not advance beyond a
certain point and that they were
frequently in their opinions paid less
than their white counterparts and they
brought forth you know an enormous
document citing all this that came from
cokes own human resources database and
and the evidence was pretty convincing
what happened in the suit they settled
these coke settled for you know more
than one hundred and seventy million
dollars
and made some great to make changes at
the board level to like to bring in more
minorities and they I think we're very
embarrassed by the whole thing because
there's nothing worse than being called
racist or you know insensitive even for
a company operating in the 21st century
go back to history started teller in the
hanger in Chicago herb Allen is on the
cook Boone and Warren Buffett is on the
club or did you say at one point I had
lost four billion dollars in value in
his story and Doug IVA stirrer who was a
CEO and they all arrived there they're
private planes they show up in the
hangar what's the reason for that hangar
meeting
this is 1999 it's December of 99 after
probably the worst you know you're in
cokes history in terms of just the
public you know issues they had the
lawsuit that had that the Belgium recall
they had another incident in which iris
chair you know talked honestly but there
was a huge outcry as a result he talked
honestly about this vending machine that
they were testing that could adjust
prices depending on the weather so
people went nuts I mean they they said
how dare they you know take advantage of
our thirst and I don't think you
temperatures 100 degrees I charged
quarter more right something like that
so there's I think you do it electronic
right solder for the late-night talk
show hosts and things but I don't think
he thought of it in terms of that I
think he thought of it in terms of being
more responsive to customers and things
but that's the way it came out and then
also the in the midst of this lawsuit
cokes highest ranking black executive a
man named Carl we're decided to step
down and that was after a reshuffle that
left him reporting not to I was thrown
but to somebody else actually was it was
Doug - who eventually became the
chairman so I'm still as Jim still
chairman yeah and where came back to
work after that but yeah there was a lot
of stuff that looked bad none of it was
immense but you know if he wanted to
make a case he could have made a case
that you know there was maybe not a need
for fresh leadership but a need for some
kind of change in attitude but by the
time they all got to the hangar in
Chicago their minds had been made up
I've astir didn't really know it was
happening but had some suspicions from
what I could tell and they meet they
meet for about 10 or 15 minutes and
Allen and Buffett till I was four
they've lost confidence in him and I've
astir not wanting to sort of rip the cup
apart doesn't try to keep the job I mean
he says okay you know where do we go
from here and they make plans to have an
emergency board meeting that weekend and
he'll resign and he'll take this package
that Alan's apparently already worked
out for him and and then he goes and he
stays for a couple of months after that
for the transition the package is worth
how much about a hundred and ninety
million dollars in terms of restricted
stock than he would have had to wait to
have access to until he formally retired
he was only 52 years old and the
restricted stock was structured so that
he'd collected its age 65 but they were
getting rid of him 13 years early they
had to to pay him for that so and he got
you know a generous pension his wife's
taking care of for all time
got to keep his car things like that but
it was that to me is like the earliest
tragedy because I think he was jumped in
a way that was both unceremonious and
possibly premature because I don't think
things have gotten a whole lot better
since he left where is he today he's
retired he's got an investment firm
called Deere Run that he manages himself
and he bought a plantation down in
southwest Georgia where he's apparently
very happy he might have made correctly
in your book that died in your opinion
Don Quixote qalaat of negative
information about Doug Alister to
Fortune magazine I do think he did yeah
you're asking about it
I did yeah what are you saying he didn't
deny it and and what what did that lead
to was there a big story at the end
portions very powerful fortune helped
create the myth that is goes Wetty I
mean he he was on the cover all the time
he and Bill Gates and Warren Buffett and
Jack Welch or sort of the you know the
pantheon of American business for years
and you know fortune is very influential
and so when fortune where it's a bad
article about Coke it gets picked up and
and listened to and you know it's not as
if there weren't facts around this I
mean certainly the belgian recall was
messy and embarrassing and not good for
the company but whether or not i sir
deserve to lose a job i mean i don't
think i agree with that did he shouldn't
have lost his job
I mean I think if they'd stuck with him
he alone kind of understood the workings
of the company as goes wet I had
designed it and maybe they wanted to get
away from that whole design maybe they
never really liked that the meaning
Allen and Buffett but I don't think
that's really true in the end is Koch
the same company with local people like
I mentioned Dan Casey in my hometown who
are still doing things locally for the
city and is it still the same company
that it was no I mean that that
connection that wonderful sort of local
guy who everybody knows and loves is
more or less gone I mean they might live
in the town still but they're not
running the plan I mean 80 percent of
the country coca-cola enterprises is
running things and they're running them
from Atlanta so as hard as you might try
to be a local bottler after that it's
just not the same so what's the big
message in this book well personally I
think that they you know they overlooked
what they were losing and in this great
sort of streamlining and restructuring
of the bottling but I also think this is
a totally American story about whether
it's better to be on your own to you
know have all this power and glory for
yourself or to work as part of a team
and I I do think that the accompanying
the bottlers had this magnificent
although you know fractious relationship
that was a system almost of checks and
balances that made coke a better brand
and the whole company stronger then than
it is right now our guest has been
Constance Hayes of the New York Times
this is her book the real thing truth
and power at the coca-cola company thank
you thank you